there are so many heartbreaking things
about this crisis and so in a way this
is like a marginal concern like who
gives a [ __ ] but one of the things that
does make me sad is like I feel like
comedies gonna be one of the hardest-hit
forms of entertainment and industries
because the audience is such an integral
part yeah I mean it's it's really sad
because you know a lot of comedy clubs
throughout the country we're probably
struggling a little bit anyway and I
don't know if all of them will come back
and of course you need people to have
disposable income to even come to the
show and you know purse strings might be
a little tight from for a bit that's why
again big fan of the universal basic
income a little bit of disposable money
do it for the comics human misery was
not enough do it for the comedy club in
Tucson yeah do it so they can go to
bananas past that [ __ ]
[Music]
recently I caught up with the phenomenal
Michelle wolf who's comedian TV
personality she performed at the White
House Correspondents Dinner a couple of
years back you might have heard about
that Michelle and I met on the trail she
actually performed with Dave Chappelle
for the campaign in Iowa so Michelle and
I became friends thrilled that she
supported my campaign and we caught up
while she was actually staying with Dave
Chappelle because she was visiting him
when we all went into quarantine Dave
said hey Michelle rather than have to
travel public transportation head back
to New York City where you're from why
don't you stay with me so Michelle has
been with Dave Chappelle in Ohio and
they've actually been performing comedy
in corn fields which are outdoors and
very socially distant so that's a that's
an image for the ages you have
world-class comedians performing in the
cornfields of Ohio but that's happening
and this is my conversation with
Michelle wolf that was recorded a little
bit ago a little bit earlier during the
Coe bid lockdown
[Music]
[Applause]
at this Chappell household I'm I can't
contribute too much but every once in a
while try to make a festive salad Dave
was very funny to point out that I did a
salad with a carrot ginger dressing and
he goes your dressing you should totally
make branded Michelle wolf dress a
carrot ginger oh my gosh can we announce
that right now yeah yeah the Michelle
wolf carrot ginger dressing when you
open the bottle there's a loud screech
so you're at Dave's house because you
were performing in the vicinity when we
all got locked down is that right well I
was supposed to do this benefit for a
school down here and the benefit got
canceled but Dave's amazing wife Elaine
was like stay I'd rather you be here
than in New York well I am sure that
where you are is at least a bit more
pastoral and natural and refreshing than
New York City because I have friends in
New York City right now and the high
point of their day is just yelling out
the window at 7:00 p.m. for the
healthcare workers I mean this is how
bad of a person I am
I was joking around last night that I'm
I'm glad we don't live near a hospital
because just like 7:00 o'clock every day
we got to do it just banging pots out in
the middle of the country so someone can
hear you well I think you've had such an
incredible journey not I don't mean like
you know where you are right now but you
know just the fact that you worked at
Bear Stearns and now you're this
world-class comedian like I thought I
was like oh my gosh like what a
transition that is so what I was most
curious about is were you like a class
clown like entertainer performer when
you were in high school or or was it
something that came to you a little bit
later I was I mean I was always kind of
like silly and and weird but I like I
mean I loved SNL and I would like
recreate the sketches in school you know
that Monday or whatever but I was never
really like I don't know I was really
serious about school you know as a nerdy
insufferably nerdy and
so it never even occurred to me that
comedy was an option yeah so when did
you actually just get in front of a
bunch of people and perform because to
me that first set of experiences must be
the most difficult and raw informative
yeah I am just to know I started working
at Bear Sterns in the summer of 2007 and
great timing perfect timing it was two
weeks after two of their hedge funds
collapsed and then March of 2008 of
course the entire bank collapsed so so
Michelle was this your fault I like to
take I like to take some of the blame
for it you know like even if I didn't do
anything I at least put the energy out
there that it could fail you know
mortgage-backed securities as the future
it's over build houses that's what you
get that's what you get for hiring
someone with no economic or business
experience no so I went to a taping of
SNL I've been such a huge fan I wanted
to know how people got started and it
turns out that almost everyone got
started with improv so I signed up for a
class and after my first class I was
just like oh I just want to do more of
this Wow I think the first class was
like a week after Bayer collapsed Wow
well you went from there you went to
another bank so you had this banker by
day comedian by night lifestyle for a
little while yeah you know we got
swallowed up by JP Morgan and I was
young and cheap relatively compared to a
lot of my bosses so I they kept me we
used this Microsoft Access program that
I kind of created and I was the only one
that knew how to use so I made myself
valuable that's a good job security tip
invent some [ __ ] that only you can use
thank you yeah but yeah I uh I got to
keep my job why I got to watch everyone
over the next year every Thursday people
got fired well I I think at that point
when when I was at Bear Sterns I
probably had like 5 VP's over me and it
was just one of those things where it
was like yeah there were too many people
you know like some of them were gonna
have to go it was just it sucks seeing
people get fired all the time even the
ones I disliked you know I kept the job
and then I kept trying to do more and
more improv two classes a week and
trying to go to as many shows as I could
and yeah that eventually turned into
stand-up that was in like 2011 I started
doing stand-up I was trying to do as
many mics as I could a night and that's
when I was like oh I gotta find a job
that's a little bit more flexible
like I can't be staying until like 7:00
p.m. and make it to these mics I need
something's gonna let me out earlier
which is when I ended up getting a
different job at a tech company this
research company it was a biochemistry
computational biochemistry research lab
where I was a recruiter because I'm not
smart enough to work there in any other
capacity bio computational researcher I
could barely remember the pitch of when
we were at career fairs so then you got
to do how many open mics a night in the
role I took they were looking for people
that had outside interests because
essentially I was doing a role that I
was overqualified for but you know their
policy was do your work do a really good
job and will support your alternative
activities outside of work so it's it's
literally the perfect job for someone
pursuing something like stand-up so I
worked there I would got to leave it
like whatever time I needed to to get
out as long as I got my work done and I
was doing three mics a night sometimes
four or five if you could fit him in and
you know travel to Brooklyn or Queens
and that's really kind of when things
started ramping up that's also when you
know I think I first got on Twitter in
2012 and I would just sit and I'd write
jokes all day while I was at work based
off of the news a lot of them awful you
know I was just starting out and I had
like five followers at the time so it
was no harm no foul I was one of them
Michelle no I wasn't I remember those
jokes
so when did you decide to just bank it
all on comedy because I feel like it's a
very big deal to actually go full-time
and I know while you're doing these open
mics they were probably paying you and
like booze you know get well first of
all sometimes for open mics you'd have
to pay you neither have to buy a drink
to even do the mic or you'd have to pay
like five dollars so at this point I'm
not really making any money in stand-up
I think they just want to make you
alcoholics in the beginning they do a
pretty good job but so the other person
that had my job at this company he ended
up leaving to go to medical school and
instead of hiring someone else they were
like actually Michelle we think you can
do both jobs and at that point I hadn't
like more responsibility at work and I
was like this isn't what I signed up for
so I made the conscious decision to try
to get fired but like the company's so
good that if I got fired they'd still
pay me severance but I had to do it in a
way that wasn't egregious so I just did
less and less work overtime this seems
like some romantic relationships I've
been a part of yeah yeah I made them
break up with me but it was actually
really hard because I hate I'm not the
kind of person that likes to like not
get stuff done and it was just like you
seem like a very hardworking
conscientious effective person so being
consciously ineffective for months must
have been really difficult it was really
hard I hate getting in trouble these
people were nice you know the company
was trying to do good things like
they're trying to they're trying to find
cures for like cancers and you know
Parkinson's and there I am just doing
less and less work so I can get
severance to quit my job overall I'm a
pretty bad person so well I mean what
that that story what that says to me is
like people will do what their
incentives are you know what I mean I
mean clearly you're not the sort of
person that likes to disappoint people
but if you set up a system where that's
the rational thing to do then like a lot
of people will do just that yeah
I mean I think I needed to do that it
was kind of my first lesson and then
like oh yeah sometimes you have to
disappoint people in order to do the
thing you want to do which I feel like
I've done throughout my career pretty
well
like a serial disappoint there it's like
the sooner I realize that not everyone's
gonna like you the more free my comedy
became not to skip ahead but I feel like
the culmination of your freedom was the
White House Correspondents Dinner in
2018 where like I thought that was the
most courageous set the guy might have
ever seen because he would really like
you know like you can always see like
the resistance going up and you were
just like plowing through it like a
fireball it was so awesome and brave and
I thought really profound really smart
like I think that might have been some
of my first exposure to your work and I
just was blown away by just how free you
seemed Thanks yeah I mean I knew as soon
as I got the call to do the dinner I
knew exactly what I wanted to do I just
wasn't sure if I'd be able to execute it
before I even said yes to it I took a
couple days to like try to write the
type of jokes that I would want to write
someday I'll put them out there in some
fashion but you me the ones that were
left off the table the table some of
them weren't admittedly just bad jokes
but other ones were like even like my
friend Keith Robinson he's a comic at
the cellar and he he's known for saying
and doing kind of whatever there was
somewhere he was like no I don't do that
that's a very useful friend to have
there but so yeah yeah but right before
I started this speech my friend mark
Normand who's also a comic and also a
big gang gang fan oh well thank you for
me he he texted me and he was like
remember if you're current if they're
cringing you're doing well so I held on
to that and as soon as they started to
tighten up which was almost immediately
I kind of sat in it and you know I'd
also had like a glass and a half a
tequila at this point so you
I was more comfortable sitting in it but
normally if an audience had been that
cringey you know of course any other
comedy show I would have been scrambling
to change but I was really having a lot
of fun witnessing their discomfort oh
that's one reason why I thought it was
so awesome and Mark's advice is so on
point because you've been in front of at
this point hundreds thousands of crowds
and ordinarily as soon as it's not
something starting to go south you
course-correct
like I did the same thing on the trail
where if I felt I was going to like a
road where like oh people don't really
feel like that was yeah any political
speech is so close to what comedies like
to you know like feeding off the crowd
and gauging their reactions and Dave's
like annoyingly good at both serious
engaging speeches I'm convinced that a
comedian should run for high office like
president like I think Dave should run
for president I think that would be
really fun and awesome and effective
because I agree with you the parallels
are uncanny yeah I mean I think he would
I think he'd be perfect for it because
the stuff he doesn't know he'd be the
kind of guy that would hire people and
put people in his cabinets and stuff
that do know what they're talking about
but he would be I mean him as a
mouthpiece is like he's gonna tell you
the truth he's gonna put things in a
logical way and he's also I said I tell
him all the time is like like will be at
some occasion and he'll pick up the
microphone to give a speech and I'm like
how do you always know how to say
exactly the thing that should be said
Senoia president but I totally and fix a
bunch of stuff and then Dave can come in
and have some fun well one reason why I
think someone who's like a straight-up
truth teller would be great is because
so much of our mishandling of these
issues is that they bury the common
sense in jargon like I feel like Bear
Stearns was an example where you had 10
layers of bureaucracy being like oh this
is way too complicated for you to ever
understand Joe Q public or
no Jane regulator or whatever it is it's
like oh no no don't worry it's okay
meanwhile they're just doing horseshit
and just like covering it up and being
like we're gonna call this one
you know mortgage-backed securities
we're gonna call this one collateralized
debt obligation it's like whatever it is
and you know that stuff's going on in
government to where if you had someone
like Davis president and someone tried
to pull [ __ ] like that he'd be like what
are you talking about someone explained
this to me in English you know like the
same thing happened with the bailout it
was like oh we're gonna quantitatively
ease and it's like what does that mean
in English it's like we're gonna just
print trillions of dollars and give it
to the banks I mean I think you actually
do a really good job of this too but
it's it's really like sometimes you just
need the logical explanation of what's
going on it might not be what you want
to hear but that doesn't mean it's not
going on I agree I think that was one of
my learnings in politics where it felt
like a lot of the politicians were just
waging Wars of keywords and symbols and
gestures that I was like I think we
should give everyone a thousand bucks a
month I think we should measure economy
by how you're doing and what I'm doing
and not how [ __ ] Amazon is doing the
movies and it felt like I was talking a
different language than any of the other
people in the race yeah I mean they're
they're all buzzwords they're all not
for me like crowd tested what's that
word focus-grouped yeah yeah focus group
yeah the quarantine has my brain working
at like 2% what is it normally at 10%
but it's less but yeah I mean like
there's really a refreshing part of you
is that you didn't sound focus-group you
were like no these are my plans and my
strategies and this is what it is well
thank you
[Music]
who is your greatest film director of
all time if you're anything like me
James Cameron might be at the top of
your list and there's a podcast called
blockbuster that just follows James
Cameron's life and career from the early
days season to a blockbuster it's like a
podcast series about James Cameron when
I think about James Cameron I think
about the Terminator aliens True Lies
avatar Titanic I remember when they were
making Titanic and as as a human being I
was like that movie looks [ __ ]
terrible and and then it comes out and
then it's like the greatest movie of all
time and I remember watching that movie
being like I will never doubt James
Cameron again painting thing he does is
magic and gold his films had you know I
remember Bill Paxton's
character and aliens being like game
over man game over that was like pre Jif
era but like me and my friends were just
saying game over to each other for like
months and months afterwards so if you
want to see what the heck James
Cameron's life story and work word check
out blockbuster season 2 the story of
James Cameron available now for free on
Apple Spotify radio com everywhere you
listen to podcasts like this one you
guys did know a sister relationship with
James Cameron
[Music]
to rewind back to this you know you
getting gently eased out of this job and
like trying to break in and spending
full time on comedy I felt like that
must have been this enormous step where
your parents our family freaking out at
this point because you'd been like the
excellent student god these
cool-sounding jobs in New York at like
these firms that they've heard of yeah I
mean also when I ended up leaving I had
enough saved up and with the severance
that I was getting I had enough saved up
to not work for a year and comedy's
really hard to explain
like why you're doing it and how you're
doing it to people that don't know it
like saying that like no but I'm working
really hard I'm going to like a bunch of
mics a night and they're like yeah but
are you getting making money are you are
you doing shows and it's like well not
yet but I'm getting there and it has to
become your life you know like you have
to kind of live or at least I did I had
to like live and breathe it and be doing
it as much as I possibly could and I
think that's the hardest part to explain
to family and friends because they're
like well you can't make time for me and
I'm like right now no I can't I have to
go after this with all I have I only
have a year and it's just hard to
explain why you don't have time for
people I have no time for you there are
50 drunken idiots awaiting my wisdom
yeah at some bar that's like a ten
minute walk from the subway in Brooklyn
you know I didn't being second-tier to
that so what was that you're like him
what was it like at the end of the year
that you had hit a particular point
where you felt like it was going to
progress and take off I mean I was I was
terrified and I think I needed to be
terrified because I didn't have any net
to fall back on you know like if I
didn't work I was gonna have to find
another job and you know I think that
kind of would have been the end
the dream I started submitting packets
for shows you know I did a packet for
Colbert The Colbert Report which was
like one of my favorite shows back then
and I towards the end of that year did a
packet for Late Night with Seth Meyers
but that show it didn't even exist yet
it was it was when it was first being
created I got fired in January of 2013
and I got hired at late-night Seth in
January of 2014 almost exactly a year
later that's a big deal so they hired
you as a writer a performer they hired
me as a writer but all the writers were
there was this agreement that like we
would potentially be characters be able
to do characters on the show and yeah I
mean it was huge it was I still remember
I thought I bombed the interview because
the interview was only about ten minutes
long from what I knew from being a
recruiter you did well if you stayed the
whole day so ten minutes I was like well
I didn't get it this is terrible I was
so sad and then I just got a call and
they hired me and I was like I couldn't
believe it
good that must have been the greatest
call ever you know it's like right at
the end of your year mark you're like
savings are evaporating I'm thinking
well what next it was amazing I was like
I couldn't I
I remember I was walking down the street
and I got the call and it started to
rain and I was like I was like this
feels like the opposite of what should
be happening but the heavens are crying
tears of joy on you you have a career in
comedy now and and working at Seth was
you know of course he's funny and all
that but he's he was such a great boss
him and Mike shoemaker who are the who's
the showrunner
and they really just like nurtured all
of us as writers and performers like you
could suggest anything you know like you
could try anything out they wanted you
to suggest the craziest thing you could
and if they didn't like it they just say
no but like there was no fault in being
you know suggesting something terrible
and that could probably be the first one
to tell you that before every good joke
I wrote there was probably 10 really bad
ones
but you know they had to get out before
I could get I have a theory that your
jokes are like stacked up into your
throat like they're just stacked up so
you have to get you know you have to get
the bad ones out before you can get the
good one rid of all the shitty ones
thank you get a Pringle in the middle of
the case one golden Pringle at the cab
one per container so you're in your
mid-20s at this period it sounds like
what was the ratio of men to women and
all these like mics you were going to
that was I mean there was probably like
of the mics a lot of times there'd be
like 30 people there and maybe five of
us were women and it sounds bad what I'm
about to say I know but it's kind of one
of my arguments when people say like
comedy should be 50/50 it's like I don't
disagree with that but the numbers
aren't there you know like when I was at
mics it was five women to maybe thirty
men and so if that's who's coming up
you're not even gonna have a pool of
fifty fifty to choose from and it's a
lot of this with like women in in
workplaces in general like you have to
be fostering them at a younger level and
then over time there will be a bigger
pool to choose from and then you can get
closer to a 50/50 ratio because when I
worked with the tech company it was the
same thing we were constantly looking
for women all the time I personally
wasn't too sad that we never hired that
many because men I have my own bathroom
like this woman has some stuff going for
there was so few of his women working
there that we each kind of claimed our
own bathroom but you know we also just
like we couldn't get a lot of women to
apply and what we should be focusing on
rather than having 5050 right now is
making sure we're letting it be a space
where women can be involved so that they
can they can train they can learn and
then they can get good at it and then
they'll be undeniable I'm going to just
guess or suppose that so these five or
six women that show up
then they're like the 25 to 30 guys I'm
just gonna guess that things were more
difficult for the five or six women that
were there in like ways minor and stupid
and in more important ways is that right
I'm not sure I mean like I I don't know
if it was just the class of comics that
I was around but like a lot of these
guys became my good friends and are
still some of my best friends and they
were always just supportive of me you
know like every mic that I went to and I
know that the situation isn't
necessarily the same for all women and I
think it's actually changed a little bit
for the worse but it was always funnies
funny not funny he's not funny
and everyone there was if you did a good
joke it was a good joke it didn't matter
if you are a man or a woman and then
like any any men that were like oh she's
a girl the actual guys who are actually
good who are still the working comics
today would be like shut up dude you're
not funny
she can do it you can't you know like
they come to your defense so like you
know maybe I just got lucky that the
people that the guys around me were kind
of good people I mean some of them
aren't necessarily good people but
they're at least you know they were they
were fair it was a meritocracy
well they recognize a good joke like
regardless of the source yeah
well I mean that's someone encouraging
I'm sorry it sounds like it might have
gotten worse since then though and one
of the things I love about comedy and it
makes me very sad what's gonna what's
happening now with this coronavirus
crisis is that no matter how good or
successful you are famous or you know in
your case you like a Netflix special and
you're like a TV show and everything but
everyone still just goes to the clubs to
do the work and get that feedback and
get that experience like there's no
escaping it yeah you know you could be
anyone at a tease exhaust level it's
like well I just got to go to the clubs
and work it out
no matter how good you get I feel like
every once in a while you'll get a gut
punch that just reminds you like yeah
don't slip you know like you got to keep
working at this like the audience is the
in generally even if you're really
famous they'll give you like a little
bit of a grace period but after a while
they'll be like okay where are the jokes
where are the jokes and
kind of keep you on your toes and keep
you honest and like honestly help you
get better or in your case to like I can
relate to aspects of this like you might
have told a joke a hundred times but
then you'll still tell it a different
time like the hundred fifth the two
hundred times just because like you're
like well I got to try something
out with this thing and then sometimes
the experiment doesn't work yeah totally
you know like any time you see a joke at
a club you don't know where that comic
is with that joke it still could be in
the oven yeah they still bake it and the
harder the difficulty the more times you
might have to say it to get it right you
know like there's jokes that I think
comics say hundreds of times before
they're like that's the funny part but
all those hundreds times before they
might have been terrible you know it
might have been a terrible joke with
like an offensive punchline and it's
like all right I know I was just trying
it I don't know sorry so instead of like
I would like comedy audiences when they
watch it at a club instead of thinking
oh that's offensive
it's like oh I just won't laugh so they
know that that way didn't work I'm going
to give them my focus group thumbs down
so they can charge a workshop or
abandoned so do you have jokes that you
were just like really attached to even
though they're now working and you're
like I'm just gonna keep on telling this
until like I could figure it out it's
like somebody like project like
resisting giving it up yeah well there's
some jokes like that but you have to
know at some point it might be like the
way you're saying it you might be
missing a line that's kind of like a
logic line that you need or you just
might not be in the point in your career
where that joke works like so much of
comedy is like being someone that they
like trust with that sort of information
that's interesting so sometimes you
might just have to put a joke on a back
burner and come back to it later just
cuz you weren't ready to tell it Wow
so even now you're just going back to
here and now at this point vast
compendium of jokes that you abandon for
whatever reason you're like oh some of
these I can now revive because I'm
cooler now essentially like I after
every time I tape a special I always
look back at the jokes that I like
couldn't get to work to be like alright
let me see if I can try this one again
and sometimes they end up working and
other times they still fail miserably
and I'm like alright back on the show
that's so interesting so you become a
writer on sets show Seth I mean I don't
know him well but like I've been on this
show and like I met him a couple of
times and he seemed like a great smart
really earnest guy to me so it doesn't
surprise me that he was looking out for
his people so then what happened next so
when I when I first started with Seth I
remember we were we were taping a promo
for the show and in between takes he he
was talking to me he goes so you're
still doing stand-up and I was like yeah
but once the show actually gets into
production I'll cut back a little and he
goes oh please don't I don't want you to
is if you can handle both do both I
don't want you to stop doing stand-up
just because you're working here and so
I did I kept doing stand-up I would do
stand-up every night I'd work at the
show every day and then at that point
I'm not doing mics anymore I'm doing
shows but I do shows every night I got
passed at the Comedy Cellar and then I
started working there every night and
just being there and doing sets there
made me an exponentially better comic
just because the people you're around
the crowds because the Comedy Cellar is
a sophisticated comedy crowd for the
most part I mean not all the time but
for the most part and they expect like a
certain level of skills so like you
really kind of have to step up your game
and I definitely credit the seller for
making me a much better comic and also
SD the woman who has been booking the
seller forever she has given me a
million opportunities and you know like
Chris Rock would be there and she'd go
Chris go down and watch Michelle she's
really funny and Trevor came that's the
first time Trevor Noah saw me she was
like go watch Michelle she's funny like
so she was really kind of always my a
cheerleader for me but so I was doing
more and more stand-up at Seth while I
was working at Seth and eventually had
been at Seth for almost two years and
Trevor had approached me he Trevor
worked at The Daily Show at this point
was worked hosts he's the host of The
Daily Show he worked there he worked his
way up
so he's the host of the
Daily Show at this point and he
approached me and was like I really love
if you could come work on my show and
also being on-air contributor and you
know after some discussions with him I
was like I do think that would be a good
move it would get me on screen a lot
more it'd be a little bit of a different
writing skill you know writing for Seth
writing jokes for Seth is very different
than writing jokes for Trevor it's not
often you can write Seth could tell a
joke that half black man from South
Africa could kind of different points of
view which helped me as a writer too and
that was fun
to be able to like stretch a different
part of my brain but yeah I went over
and I started working at the Daily Show
and yeah so you said something that I
think is really interesting you said hey
I went from mics to shows like at what
point does a comedian get like a slot on
the billing I'm sure after you're like
hey like now from you know Late Night
with Seth Meyers and they were like but
are you never gonna get more work than
from other comics other comics are like
they're the ones who recommend you for
things they'll put you on your shows and
then that's how it starts happening
first comics will they'll be like hey I
run a show at this at this bar can you
do a set on it and you do that you do
well the show other comics see you other
comics put you on their show there's a
couple like comedy Booker's that kind of
work this circus of shows throughout the
city and they'll see you at shows
they'll start booking you on these
bigger shows and it's kind of just like
it's a waterfall effect after a while
but it is really just word-of-mouth and
showing up and like killing I mean you
have to like continually you know like
it's when no one knows who you are you
really have to kill at least for me I
really thought that I had to like try to
knock it out of the park every time so
who are some of the comedian's that then
reached out to you and were like hey I
really like you I think you're funny
like you should join me on the show you
know there was a lot of people that were
just running a lot of bar shows at that
time I Joe list would put me on his
shows again
Norman would put me on his shows this
guy Jared Logan who is actually out in
LA now you know Dan Soder would
recommend me to anyone who would listen
let's see who else there's this one
Booker at the time Jeremy Levin Bob
that's cool I mean you still remember
them I mean sure you'd feel really great
about them yeah yeah and a lot of you
know a lot of them are comics who are
still working and we you know all those
guys they're amazingly funny and good
dudes and you kind of grow up with them
you know and it's like it's it's a weird
family but like like I definitely miss
being on stage right now but honestly
like just hanging out with the comics is
I miss that a lot too I mean luckily I
have Dave but like hanging out with
comics and just like talking and because
they really become like it becomes this
family sure I mean you're around them
like I would say Brotherhood but I don't
want people to think it's sexist it's
not sexist it's it's just like you know
it's a family we definitely need a term
for like fraternity across genders it's
like Brotherhood sisterhood like smash
together exactly every word I was
thinking of people are gonna be like see
it is a boys club and I'm like no it's
not a boys club it's just it's like a
sorority
[Music]
how did Seth take it when you were like
hey I think I want to go work for Trevor
I actually when I told Seth I actually
cried a little bit because I loved being
there and he had given me so many
opportunities and he was like you have
to go you have to that's it's the next
best step for you I'm so proud of you
I'm so happy for you I'll miss you a lot
but you have to go so he was awesome
again hands-down the best yeah
and in same with Mike shoemaker they
were so supportive and there's still
great people who I I could reach out to
it anytime and and they'd be there there
it's nice the thing that like I think
the thing that sometimes gets
misconstrued is that like a lot of the
guys out there are trying to help women
I've worked for a lot of men and like
everyone that's gotten me something has
has been a man you know like Hannibal
Buress recommended me to Chris Rock to
write on the Oscars Chris is his first
guy who introduced me to Dave you know
like Neal Brennan offered to direct this
snapchat show I did a long time ago like
it's really hard for me to say that like
it's a boys club when it's like yeah I
just named a lot of dudes but they were
all so helpful and pivotal in my career
like they they've all shouted my name to
anyone who would hear it I don't I don't
like that that's not the you know that
that part of the story doesn't get told
oh that's a beautiful part of the story
and you're telling it right now and
certainly I think a lot of people
appreciate it like I know at least a
couple of those people and they seem
like that kind of human being it's like
if they see someone who's talented and
up-and-coming and they can help they'll
help yeah yeah and you know I I know not
everyone's good but you know I've had
great experiences with them and you know
a lot of people like is it hard to be a
woman in comedy and I'm like well first
of all this is all I've ever been in
comedy so I don't know how it's
different you don't have that second
control group if you like you know
here's here's Sam wolf dressed in drag
do with the same
like in a deep voice like the Mulan of
comedy but yeah I mean so and also you
know like I've only been doing stand-up
this is now my ninth year and I've had
two specials several web series and an
unsuccessful television show you know so
like I I can't say it's been harder for
me obviously everyone has different
experiences but like I I can't say it's
been hard to be a woman in comedy on my
end well you've been very very
successful and you mean you're immensely
talented like you know and brave mean
I've seen your work and loved it before
we had a chance to meet in person I mean
one of the things there are so many
heartbreaking things about this crisis I
mean people are dying people are losing
their jobs like our entire country is
being shaken to its core and so in a way
this is like a marginal concern like who
gives a [ __ ] but one of the things that
does make me sad is like I feel like
comedies gonna be one of the hardest hit
forms of entertainment and industries
because the audience is such an integral
part and you're at a point now where you
know you can like broadcast stuff or
like put jokes out there and you've got
like a big platform but it makes me
really sad thinking about the next
generation of comics that are trying to
do what you did like go to the the open
mics and everything else cause like when
is the New York comedy seem gonna look
anything like it used to look like what
does that time frame look like no one
knows but it's certainly not going to be
today tomorrow next month maybe not even
next year yeah I mean it's it's really
sad because you know a lot of comedy
clubs throughout the country
we're probably struggling a little bit
anyway and I don't know if all of them
will come back you know so there's gonna
be less clubs to perform at which means
it's gonna be more competitive to get
weekends at clubs and that's gonna mean
less and less people get to kind of go
on the road and work out an hour and try
new things in front of different
audiences and of course you need people
to have disposable income to even come
to the show and you know purse strings
might be a little tight from for a bit
that's why again big fan of the
universal basic income
a little bit of disposable money
do it for the comics misery was not
enough do it for the comedy club in
Tucson yeah do it so you can go to
bananas past that [ __ ] but yeah and I
agree with you it is sad like I mean
there's definitely been times in history
where like there's been bad things that
happen where you see one of the things
that drops off is art yes because it's
just it's hard to do if there's no money
or free time or yeah and that's just
that is very sad you know I mean they're
certainly gonna be a lot of podcasts I
heard there's been a real run on podcast
mics but it's like a very different
thing that someone going through the
crucible you went through because how
many freaking sets did you do in person
while you were figuring it out it must
have been thousands yeah I mean like
it's there's nothing that replaces going
on the road as a comic you know like
doing those weekends at like small
cities throughout the country just kind
of like running it into the ground and
like throwing stuff at the wall you know
you've really gotta like look I'm using
so many turns of phrase there's there's
nothing that replaces that and as a
comic you have to go on the road you
have to be able to have those
opportunities to get better and there's
no replacing that well I know you're
right because the same thing happened to
me on the trail running for president
and like you know when I started out
there would be the small group of people
I would be like you know there because
they were just curious and no one really
was paying much attention it was almost
the equivalent of like open mics my open
mic was I showed up to New Hampshire in
a Subaru at this coffee shop and there
was a grand total of one person there I
was like hey you're a candidate for
president and they were like yes I was
like fantastic so so those were like the
lumps I took but you really evolved as
results like there is no way that I
could have done what I did down the
stretch when it's like a you know here's
like an arena full of like thousands of
people who are not there to see you
they're there to see Bernie but whatever
but but at that point it was like
repetition number you know like mm and
so then you have different muscles
you're like a different type of
performer not to say that you know
politician equals performer but they
certainly perform a development
definitely yeah and there is no way you
can get to point B from point A without
thousands of live events and so it is
going to be very difficult to replace
that for the next generation like I
don't think that technology and podcast
and Twitter really can replace it yeah
that's why I get kind of I get kind of
annoyed when everyone's like well the
new normal the new normal I'm like no no
we shouldn't be settling for this as
like a new normal like we should look
for solutions that allow us to gather
and socialize because that's what we
should be able to do as creatures you
know like that's the thing that scares
me the most is like when you can't be
around people different than you and you
can't discuss ideas and have
conversations you become more and more
divided and the idea that that is a like
a real possibility is it's kind of
terrifying I think no you know it's one
reason why I think the role of comedy
has really grown is that it seems like
it's one of the few ideological meeting
grounds like you know you could have
someone say something and it doesn't
fall neatly into a political camp you
know you could have people with
different ideas or alignments or like
the same stage within 30 seconds of each
other
I think comedies role is actually very
important because of what you just said
it's like how the heck can you have
meetings of ideas or thoughts if you
know where each in our own little bubble
yeah I mean a lot of people you know I
think because of the Correspondents
Dinner people think I'm like a crazy
bleeding-heart liberal and I'm
definitely a liberal but like I think to
do your best in comedy you kind of have
to live in the grey you have
to be able to see everything at their
face value and then cuz there's plenty
of times when I'm like I'm like the
Wrights not wrong on this you know like
and you kind of have to let your idea
lodge logical values kind of like go
away for a little bit in order to see
that and then to maybe put it in a joke
form to point it out to the rest of the
world you can point it out right in
front of the president and they're gay
so what was your reaction to the
firestorm after the Correspondents
Dinner that you probably knew was coming
you're like if I do my job there won't
be this like you know fire sir I mean
some of it struck me as [ __ ] like
that like some of this stuff where it
was like oh you somehow like you know
anti-woman or you know I thought I was
like that seems like a very strange
reading but yeah but what was your
reaction afterwards I was well first of
all I was I was pretty shocked that they
thought I made fun of Sara's looks
because literally two days before the
dinner I had a I had some looks based
jokes in there for Kellyanne and I took
them out because one of my friends who
read it was like I think you should take
out the jokes about looks because I I
have a feeling that's what the media
will make it about and I was like you
know that's a good call I was sad
because I really loved the joke but it
was a good call and I was like you're
right let's do that I took out the joke
and then I was like wait but I think
you're still gonna get mad at looks I
should have told the joke I really
wanted to tell these get mad at me for
the right reason you know but that's
when I was like oh the media is even
more like complicit than I thought they
were you know like when like I think was
like Andrea Mitchell and Maggie Haberman
and Myka whatever her last she when they
they specifically you know got mad at me
and I was like oh you guys either are
willfully ignorant or you're trying to
maintain some sort of access that you
have and I tend to believe it was the
latter because I don't think any of them
are stupid enough to actually think that
that was a
looks based joke but again as soon as
the headlines written that's the it
doesn't matter what the truth is as soon
as that headlines out there that's what
people believe one of the funniest
things is that my manager he got all the
headlines from cuz I was on like every
newspaper the next day which was a big
shock to me I didn't I knew it what I
was doing I just didn't know it would
blow up as big as it did I had similar
experiences I my manager took all the
headlines and he framed all the good
ones and then next to it he framed all
the bad ones so it's a great picture
that has all the good headlines right
next to all the bad headlines and it's
just so hilarious how it can be taken in
two completely different ways of course
people were gonna say negative things
that to me was a good thing like that
honestly as it made me a more confident
standup the fact that I was like yeah
you know what you're gonna do stuff that
people are gonna hate but I'd rather
some people hate me and some people love
me then a lot of people just feel about
me and yeah I mean as like an artist
like if you try and avoid ever pissing
anyone off then like that's a very very
narrow lane yeah yeah you're gonna get
you're gonna get boxed in and it's not
gonna be at least for me it wouldn't be
that much fun but you know maybe I also
just like stepping on toes a little bit
but the thing that really like like
warmed my heart
was the fact that all of these comics
came to my defense like everyone even
people that like maybe don't necessarily
like me came to my defense you know like
everyone was there like and people I'd
never met before but always held in such
high regard like Letterman said great
things about me Dave said great things
and this is before I even really knew
Dave like just people that I've always
loved and held in such high regard and
then also comics at my level comics
below me all these comics came to my
defense and I was like that's that's
kind of the beauty of the comedy
community like
long as you're telling jokes like they
should have your back that's really
beautiful that is the community and that
must have felt great because people who
you hold in really high esteem and you
know admire like they're like oh look
they like know who I am and they
approved of my work that really would be
all yeah yeah it's crazy like I mean
I've never met David Letterman I I mean
I watched his show growing up and like I
never got to do stand-up on a show cuz I
just wasn't ready when he was still on
the air but I would have loved to but
then the fact that he saw it and liked
it and said nice things about me it's
really cool it was really cool for
someone who never got the opportunity to
meet him before yeah that would feel
really good and you do deserve it I mean
when I saw it I was like this was really
funny brave excellent like and as
someone who's like been in environments
where like you kind of know which way
the crowds going I just like admired
your your fortitude you're like just
guts it was so awesome
oh thanks yeah I had it I mean I had a
great time plus the you know the tequila
help too yeah so what do you have next
because I know someone like you is like
always working always creating what are
you working on that we can look forward
to I have a new special that I'm ready
to tape almost as soon as we get out of
this I my last special came out in
December of last year and then this one
I was able to write it in like a month
and I'm really excited about it it's
kind of it's kind of all about one topic
is that topic universal basic income I
use all your talking points but do you
did you notice that like everyone kind
of stole like not stole but took all
your ideas after you got out of the race
and kind of peppered them into their own
you know I did see some of that I just
took it as flattery
you know where it's like yeah I think I
said at one point it's like I'm either
going to win or the other candidates are
gonna sound like me by the end and so
the fact that the idea is stuck you know
made me happy and proud because you know
I just wanted to see the solutions get
across the finish line and if other
people are talking about them and you
know I don't know if you got your
stimulus but like millions of probably
made way too much but like millions of
Americans got this check in the mail and
you know like I have a feeling that this
is here to stay so certainly would never
wish this crisis but yeah I did notice
that it seems like a lot of the
campaign's ideas have borne fruit and
I'm grateful to everyone who supported
the campaign including you and Dave
obviously and others because I feel like
we did our country a great service we
like advanced really big important ideas
right in the nick of time yeah you
really um it was very forward-thinking
[Music]
[Applause]
I've got this this new stand-up set that
I want to do and then I'm also writing a
couple things I have a miniseries that
I'm working on that I'm really excited
about and a couple other potential
projects that who knows if they'll get
off the ground or not but they're things
that are exciting and fun for me to do
so but you know stand-up is always
hopefully gonna be my backbone because
it's the thing I love to do the most
know what one of the things we have to
make sure it happens that stand-up
continues to exist and comes back and
I'm just imagining what it would take a
lot of it frankly is just going to be
whether we have the right testing so
that people have confidence like imagine
if you if you went to a comedy club and
you knew everyone in that club had been
tested and is negative and you're fine
then you're fine you can relax if you
don't know that then it's gonna be
really really hard because it'll be like
oh like someone's breathing in my
direction you know that's not exactly
like a humorous environment yeah
especially like I mean the tables are
close together you know you might be
sitting with someone you don't know and
you know you're laughing some stuffs
potentially coming out of your mouth you
know like it's a it's a petri dish for
sharing a airborne disease like that but
I really hope that we can figure out a
way to do live events that people are
comfortable I do think testing is the
big thing I think also the move is gonna
be you know smaller venues not huge
crowd size you know like I don't think
we're gonna see arena shows for a little
bit for quite a bit longer than we'll
see smaller venue shows but that's
totally fine with me because I'd rather
play a club than a big space any day not
playing a ton of big spaces but you were
playing some big spaces I mean you know
it's like I saw you and like yeah you
know one of the things in and this is
like something that is very practical
and I'd have to ask you so imagine
you're performing a set in a club but
the club has these like markers on the
floor where like each person has you
know six feet around them and instead of
it being a packed intimate vibe where
people are on top of each other and like
drinking it's like the equivalent of
like 40% full like how does that sound
to you because that might unfortunately
be like the the reality and I know as
someone who's you know smoking in front
of gatherings ordinarily speaking in
front of a mostly empty venue is not
positive like you're like energy or
performance or feedback but that is like
an approach like how much would that
impact you and other comics if like you
were performing to essentially like a
third full clubs I mean it definitely
would hurt your paycheck for sure but
then also you're gonna have to get used
to laughs sounding different you know
cuz like part of the beauty of a comedy
club is that you're all packed together
and it's almost a contagious environment
where you can I mean and maybe literally
where you can get the laughs rolling and
kind of like people feel more
comfortable to laugh when they see other
people laugh so it's like it creates an
energy and an uproar but if you're that
far apart you're really just gonna have
to get used to things sounding different
and being like okay that joke worked
even though the laugh seems about a
third of what it normally would yeah I
mean that's true these are some of the
things that we're going to have to be
looking at in the days ahead
especially for again for for people who
are trying to be like you frankly
because you know you achieved enough
success where you have projects that
aren't as dependent upon that
economically but you know I am thinking
about how we can start to bring back
every type of institution from comedy
clubs to schools to places of employment
restaurants because so many people's
careers and livelihoods depend upon us
eventually figuring out how people can
have the confidence to come out and
enjoy themselves yeah I am I
I definitely like I agree that everyone
should stay home but I also I'm like
what are we doing psychologically to
people the fear of being in a crowd a
fear of being near people it's like how
do you repair that damage how do you do
you repair
Damon's yeah like what are you and and
then it's also like okay we maybe we get
a vaccine we get enough tests everyone
kind of either knows or if you you know
if you get it there's an easy cure you
know drinking Lysol perhaps but even
after that's happened like our people
gonna be comfortable being that close
anymore it's it's yeah it's going to be
a long road back and like the new world
probably does not look like what we've
been accustomed to throughout your life
in my life like 20 19 20 22 is not going
to look like 2019 in terms of people's
attitudes of getting together even if we
do have some of the vaccines and tests
that we need and I agree with you to
that stay at home find the curve yes yes
yes but we do have to start evaluating
how we reopen targeted parts of our
economy before we have a vaccine because
a vaccine could be 18 months away or
more and it's not realistic to say to
everyone like what we're gonna be in for
that timeframe if you look at other
countries some of them are starting to
try and reopen there are choices because
if you reopen too fast like you could
cause a resurgence but but these are the
questions we have to grapple with you
just can't take one extreme or the other
certainly the people who are like open
everything I mean know that that's super
stupid and deadly but also it's like
everyone stay home forever like that's
not really an answer you know we're
going to we're going to have to peek our
heads out sometime I do want the world
to I mean maybe like overall be safer
but like I do hope people are striving
to make it look like it used to in terms
of like gatherings and things like that
like I hope there's people smart enough
working on stuff that can allow for the
technology that and like medical
advancements that we can get back to the
life's we knew that there's something
fundamental about a concert a rally a
gathering like a night out I agree with
you that if you lose that it's something
very human where that there's just
something
really important and profound about us
being able to get together in that kind
of setting and I agree with you that's
what we should be aspiring for hopefully
we'll get there
you know before too long passes and I
think our culture is changing through
this but you know hopefully we can make
it change in some ways that are positive
I mean I'm deeply concerned about some
of the damage that we're wreaking on
people's lives but you and I are gonna
be some of the people that help bring
people back and I don't know about you
Michelle maybe you you feel this but
like I feel this responsibility to put
good stuff out there because you know
people just need more good stuff out
there yeah I mean like I keep sharing
you know video clips of old stand-up and
things like that and I it's a weird
situation to be in where it's like I
don't want to do stand-up on you know
Instagram or anything like that cuz it's
not the right way to do stand-up but
yeah I mean I think keeping people
entertained and positive and distracted
yeah we all have our roles to play and
certainly you know we just have to do
all we can but thank you for taking this
time you know I hope you stay safe there
please say hey to Dave and Elaine and
the family you know I was supposed to
visit I had the flights booked and the
whole thing and then we all got sent
home on locked out like I didn't I
didn't bother showing Dave like the
tickets to Ohio just feel like proof but
you should know that like though I guess
it's the case that if I was able to go
there you probably would not have been
there so it's not like I would have been
visiting you anyway but you might have
gotten to stay in this beautiful guest
cottage I might have been in that casa
de casa - Michelle they should name that
house after you
[Music]